Willkommen an der Militärakademie in Wr. Neustadt.
Mein Name ist Oberst Markus Reisner. Ich bin der
Leiter der Forschungs- und Entwicklungsabteilung
und heute wollen wir uns in einem neuen Video
ansehen, wie sich die Schlacht im Donbass
darstellt und zwar am Tag 96 des Konflikts.
Dazu ganz kurz als Abholpunkt die Situation in
der Woche 14, Tag 96: Die russischen Kräfte haben
massiv versucht, das Schwergewicht in den Osten
des Landes zu verlagern und versuchen hier im
Raum Donbass die Entscheidung herbeizuführen, die
sich in einer klassischen Zangenoperationen
ausdrückt. Nämlich einmal der Versuch, aus
dem Norden vorzustoßen und einmal aus dem
Süden. Was wir jetzt machen wollen ist, wir wollen
anhand vier ausgewählter Faktoren die Situation
analysieren, so wie sie sich jetzt darstellt.
Diese Faktoren sind einerseits das Gelände,
dann die Zeit, die Information und das Lagebild
sowie die Kraft. Wenn wir uns als Abholpunkt
ansehen von unserer letzten Präsentation die
Situation, so wissen wir, dass sich die Masse
der Kämpfe im Osten des Donbass abspielt, nämlich
grob um die Stadt Kramatorsk. Hier gibt es eine
nördliche Zange und eine südliche Zange. Beide
Zangen werden von den Russen vorangetrieben, um
eine Entscheidung im Donbass herbeizuführen.
Wenn wir uns die Frontlinie des 3. April
ansehen, so sehen wir im Zentrum die Städte
Kramatorsk und Slowjansk und herum angeordnet die
russischen Kräfte, die versuchen, hier
eine Entscheidung herbeizuführen.
Wenn wir das jetzt ins Gelände legen im Vergleich,
dann erscheint das auf den ersten Blick relativ
klein im vergleich zum Ausmaß dera ukrainischen
Landes, aber wenn wir das vergleichen
mit zum Beispiel Österreich, sieht man, wie
groß dieser mögliche Kessel sich tatsächlich
darstellt. Ich habe also auf der einen Seite hier
Wien mit Eisenstadt, dem Neusiedlersee und der Donau,
grob eine Distanz von 40 Kilometern, die die gleiche
Distanz darstellt wie im Kessel selbst, wo die
Situation sich wie folgt im Moment darstellt: Dass
noch 20 Kilometer fehlen von russischer Seite, um
diesel Kessel südwestlich von Sjewjerodonezk zu
schließen. Hier noch einmal dargestellt, um
sich die Ausdehnungbewusst zu machen.
Sehen wir uns nun anhand des Faktors
Gelöände die nördliche Zange an. Die nördliche Zange
war geprägt durch Kämpfe im April/Mai, wo die
russische seite versucht hat, eine Entscheidung
herbeizuführen und in die Tiefe vorzustoßen. Im
April fanden die Kämpfe vor allem im Raum Isjum
statt. Isjum, eine natürliche Enge, die die
Russen erst überwinden konnten, nachdem sie
den hier dominierenden Fluss, Siwerskyj Donez,
durch zwei Pontonbrücken überquert haben und in
die Tiefe vorgestoßen sind. Die ukrainische Seite
hat hier intelligent reagiert und hat ebenfalls
versucht, den Fluss zu forcieren mit 2 Pontonbrücken und
die Russen in der Flanke anzugreifen. Das ist zwar
gelungen, aber die Russen konnten diese Brücken
zerstören. Auch hier konnten die Ukrainer noch
darauf reagieren, indem sie versucht haben, leichte
Kräfte bei Tag und bei Nacht durch ein sehr
einfaches Verfahren - nämlich durch das Überwinden
des Gewässers mit kleinen Schiffen und Schlauchbooten -
zu überqueren und weiter hier Druck aufrecht zu
erhalten auf die russischen Kräfte im raum Isjum
und südlich davon. Die Russen haben nun versucht,
das Schwergewicht zu verlagern weiter in den Osten,
das heißt, den Angriff kürzer zu stecken. Was haben
sie im Osten versucht? Das gleiche, das sie vorher
erfolgreich bei Isjum durchgeführt haben: Sie haben
ebenfalls versucht, den Fluss zu überqueren.
Sehen wir uns das kurz im Detail an: Der Auftakt
war eine Brückenüberquerung am 2. Mai grob
hier in diesem Bogen nordwestlich von Siewerskyj Donez.
Es hat funktioniert und russische Kräfte
konnten auf die andere Seite vorstoßen, wo sie aber
von ukrainischen Kräften abgefangen worden sind
und wieder zurückgetrieben worden sind. Daraufhin
haben die Russen es an anderer Stelle probiert:
bei Jampil, ebenfalls hier, erfolgreich den Fluss
überquert, aber aufgrund der starken Gegenwehr
der ukrainischen Kräfte wieder zurückgedrängt.
Schlussendlich hat man es nochmal zentral in der
Mitte probiert, indem man hier versucht hat,
bei Bilohoriwka eine Entscheidung herbeizuführen
und beginnend mit 9. Mai über zwei Pontonbrücken
den Siwerskyj Donez überschritten hat. Die ukrainische
Seite, die bereits vorgewarnt war durch diese
wiederholten Brückenüberquerungen, man sagt bis
zu neun Mal wurde es versucht, haben Kräfte bereit-
gestellt und hier zentral durch Unterstützung
mit Artillerie angegriffen und die russischen
Kräfte endgültig zerschlagen. Das Entscheidende
ist, dass die russische Seite erkannt hat, dass ein
Überschreiten des Flusses nichtmöglich
ist. Andererseits hat die ukrainische
Seite diese Situation nur für sich entscheiden
können, weil sie Kräfte aus dem Süden herangeführt
hat. Sehen wir uns daher die südliche Zange an. Die
südliche Zange ist geprägt von einem sehr flachen
Gelände. Hier haben zwar die Russen versucht
aus dem Süden weiter vorzustoßen, aber aufgrund der
eingesetzten ukrainischen Kräfte waren diese Vorstöße nicht vonErfolg geprägt. Damit konnten die Ukrainer auch
Teile dieser Kräfte Richtung Norden verschieben.
Zusätzlich hat man noch weitere Verstärkungen
herangeholt, dazu gehören vor allem die Kräfte der
Territorial-Einheiten aus dem Westen der Ukraine.
Hier hat man zentral über die Übersetzstellen
bei Dnipro und Saporischschja insgesamt 7
Brigade-Äquivalente herangeführt. 3 im April und
4 im Mai. Diese Territorial-Einheiten wurden vor
allem eingesetzt, um die bereits im Einsatz
befindlichen ukrainischen Kräfte lokal zu
verstärken in der Abwehr gegen die russischen
angreifenden Kräfte. Der zweite Faktor, der jetzt
ganz wesentlich ist in diesen wochen im April und Mai,
ist der Faktor Abnützung inklusive der Zeit.
Der Faktor Zeit war bestimmend, denn über die Zeit
hat die russische Seite ihren großen Vorteil
ausgespielt und das ist der massive Einsatz von
vor allem Artillerie aber auch von Luftunterstützung.
Das heißt, in den Wochen des April und Mai
haben wir vor allem gesehen den Einsatz von
Kampfhubschraubern aber auch von Jagdflugzeugen
und den massiven Einsatz von Artillerie. Und gerade
diese Artillerie hat einen sehr devastierenden Effekt
auf die ukrainischen Stellungen. Denn aufgrund von
tagelangem Feuer war es so, dass die Moral der ukrainischen
Soldaten in den Stellungen zunehmend am abnehmen
war. Damit möchte ich zum nächsten Faktor
überleiten, nämlich zur Information beziehungsweise
zum Lagebild. Sehen wir uns nochmal kurz den Frontbogen an: Hier erkennt man, dass die ukrainische Seite
den Vorteil der sogenannten inneren Linie hat. Das
heißt, sie kann Kräfte aus dem zentralen Raum immer
verschieben zur Unterstützung, wo notwendig. Die
russische Seite ist jedoch gefordert, von Außen
wo möglich eine Entscheidung herbeizuführen.
Schlussendlich bekam die ukrainische Front
einen Riss und dieser Riss stellte sich dar bei
der Ortschaft Popasna, einem wichtigen
Stützpunkt in der Südfront der ukrainischen
Kräfte. Hier gelang es den Russen, vom 5. auf
den 6. Mai, einen Durchbruch zu erzielen.
Um diesen Durchbruch verstehen zu können, sehen
wir uns kurz die Taktik an. Hier am Beispiel von
Popasna, wo dieser Durchbruch passiert ist.
Die im Donbass befindlichen ukrainischen
Kräfte, vor allem auch Elite-Verbände, waren
in der Verteidigung vor allem abgestützt auf
Stützpunkte, die angelegt worden sind vor allem
entlang der Ortschaften. Das Zwischengelände
wurde entweder durch Feuer überwacht oder bei
Bedarf durch einen Reserven-Einsatz bedient. Als nun
die russische Seite angegriffen hat und der
Druck immer stärker geworden ist, hat man versucht,
durch die nachgeführten Territorial-Einheiten eine
Verdichtung der Kräfte durchzuführen. Das heißt,
vor allem dass Zwischengelände wurde durch
diese Territorial-Kräfte aufgefüllt. Die russische
Seite hat das erkannt und hat entsprechend darauf
reagiert. Der Hauptangriff war eigentlich
ein Bindungsangriff auf den Stützpunkt (besetzt
durch die Elite-Einheiten der ukrainischen Armee)
und nebenbei hat man versucht, mit einer Umfassung
die schwache Stelle im Norden und Süden des
Stützpunktes anzugreifen und bei einem Durchbruch
rasch in die Tiefe vorzustoßen - mit einer dritten
Staffel oder gar Reserve. Damit war es möglich, die
zentralen Verbände der ukrainische Seite in Popasna zu
umgehen und in die Tiefe vorzustoßen. Das Problem der
Territorial-Einheiten war, dass sie weder über die
Ausbildung verfügten, noch über die Bewaffnung, wie
zum Beispiel Panzerabwehr-Kapazitäten, um hier
dementsprechend etwas entgegen zu setzen.
Um das kurz darzustellen, zeigen wir Ihnen ein kurzes
Video, das so eine Gefechtssituation zeigt.
Das Ergebnis dieser russischen Taktik und Gefechts-
technik war, dass es gelang, bei Popasna einen
Durchbruch zu erzielen und es entstand etwas,
das die Russen als "die Blume" bezeichnen:
Die Blume drückt sich darin aus, dass es ihnen möglich
war, aus Popasna heraus Richtung Norden, Westen und
Süden vorzustoßen, wie z.B. hier auf diesem Blatt
Artemiwsk, das wir hier in der Karte sehen.
Die Idee war, diesen Durchbruch zu nutzen
und rasch in die Tiefe vorzustoßen, am besten
Richtung Norden, Richtung Siwerskyj Donez,
und die Kräfte im Nordosten einzuschließen.
Wenn wir uns den 8. Mai im Vergleich zum 24. Mai ansehen,
dann sehen wir wie massiv dieser Vorstoß war und
wir sehen, dass die Bedrohung vor allem darin
besteht, dass eine wichtige Verbindungslinie in
diesem entstehenden Kessel möglicherweise von
der russischen Seite kontrolliert wird. Sehen wir
uns jetzt die Entwicklungen der letzten Tage an.
Hier kann man sehr gut erkennen, dass die russische
Seite, nachdem sie im Norden keinen Erfolg
hatte, sich vor allem auf den Süden konzentriert
beziehungsweise auch zentral versucht,
eine Entscheidung herbeizuführen.
Und wir erkennen hier am Vergleich dieser beiden
Skizzen, dass die zentralen Versorgungslinien
die T0513 und T1302 von der russischen
Seite bedroht werden, vor allem bereits die
T1302, wo gerade heftige Kämpfe um die Kontrolle
dieser Versorgungslinie geführt werden. Warum
sind diese Versorgungslinien wichtig? Weil nur
durch diese Versorgungslinien kann einerseits
ein Nachschub in den Kessel sichergestellt werden
bzw. wäre es möglich, im Falle des Falles, sich aus
diesem Kessel zurückzuziehen. Die Frage ist: Was
können die Ukrainer jetzt tun, um diesen Kessel zu
vermeiden? Das Erste, das wir sehen, ist der Einsatz
von Artilleriesystemen und vor allem von Artillerie-
systemen, die vom Westen geliefert worden sind, wie
zum Beispiel dieses System 155mm M777.
Die Artillerie ist deswegen wichtig,
weil es die einzige Fähigkeit ist - nachdem
kaum Luftunterstützungsmittel von ukrainischer
Seite vorhanden sind - um die russische Artillerie
bekämpfen zu können und damit diesen Abnutzungs-
faktor wieder im Sinne der Ukraine auszugleichen.
Interessant ist: Wenn man die Geschütze im Einsatz betrachtet,wie auf diesem Bild, so sieht man,
dass diese Geschütze nicht komplett geliefert worden
sind. Es scheint so, als wenn Teile fehlen. Diese
Teile sind aber wichtig, denn sie würden die Geschütze
befähigen, ihre Maximalleistung ausspielen zu
können und das ist vor allem der Einsatz von
Endphasen-gesteuerter Munition wie diese Granate
vom Typ Excalibur. Das heißt, die Ukrainer haben
diese Geschütze bereits im Einsatz, die den Vorteil
einer hohen Reichweite haben. Sie können sie aber nicht
zu 100% ausnützen. Wir sehen auch,
dass die Russen sehr gezielt versuchen, diese Geschütze
zu zerstören. So gibt es bereits ein Video, wo man
erkennen kann, dass eine Batterie dieser M777
offensichtlich zerstört worden ist. Sehen wir
uns einen weiteren Game-Changer an: Das ist
der Einsatz von sogenannten Kamikaze-Drohnen
oder "loitering munition" genannt. Hier wissen wir, dass
von amerikanischer Seite vor allem die Systeme
"Switchblade" aber auch "Phoenix Ghost" geliefert
worden sind. Wir erkennen hier in diesem Bild und auch
in dem Video, dass die "Switchblade 300" bereits
eingesetzt wird. Wir erkennen an diesen
Fotos auch, dass die russische Seite schon diese Drohnen
erbeutet hat. Das Problem ist, das System 300 eignet
sich zwar für eine Bekämpfung von Infanterie-Zielen,
um aber mechanisierte Kräfte bekämpfen
zu können, bräuchte man das System 600, von denen
wir noch keine im Einsatz gesehen haben und es nicht
klar ist, ob diese Systeme tatsächlich dieUkrainer
im Donbass schon erreicht haben.
Das nächste Problem, das wir haben, ist das Problem der
Panik. Wir sehen, dass die Russen im April und Mai
massiv Druck ausgeübt haben auf diesen Frontbogen,
obwohl sie das Problem der äußeren Liniehaben,
können sie rasch ihr Schwergewicht wechseln.
Wir haben also einerseits den Vorstoß bei Popasna,
der sich aus russischer Sicht gut entwickelt hat.
Wir haben aber laufende andere Angriffe: nach wie
vor im Raum Isjum, in letzter Konsequenz weiter
im Süden, wo es den Russen
gelungen ist vorzustoßen, aber auch bei Lyman,
das gefallen ist, bzw. bei Sjewjerodonezk, wo sehr
heftige Kämpfe toben. Wie man erkennen kann, kann
es der Fall sein, dass diese Vorstöße relativ rasch
dazu führen, dass sich Kessel bilden und das ist
den ukrainischen Soldaten natürlich bewusst. Und
das Problem ist, dass vor allem die Territorial-Einheiten
nicht über diese gute Ausbildung verfügen,
um hier lange und nachhaltig Widerstand zu leisten.
Wir erkennen das an mehreren Faktoren. Das Erste
ist: Wir sehen immer mehr zerstörte Brücken. Brücken,
die von der Ukraine gesprengt werden. Warum? Weil
sie versuchen, so die russischen Angriffe zu
verzögern. Das nächste Indiz ist der Umstand,
dass von ukrainischer Seite befohlen worden ist,
sich in der Tiefe für eine mögliche Verteidigung
einzurichten, also zum Beispiel entlang des
flusses Dnipro, wo man ganz klar erkennen
kann, dass man verhindern möchte, wenn es zu einer
Bewegung der Russen Richtung Westen kommt, diese
nicht mehr auffangen zu können. Und wenn wir uns
die Kräfte anschauen, die sich möglicherweise in
diesem sich entwickelnden Kessel befinden, so
sehen wir das es circa zwischen 10.000 und 12.000
Soldaten sind, plus der Zivilbevölkerung,
die nicht flüchten konnte, die hier möglicherweise
eingeschlossen werden kann. Anhand von einigen
Videos, ich habe hier als Beispiel 13 Videos
angeführt, sehen wir dass die Moral der ukrainischen
Soldaten sehr unter diesem Abnutzungseffekt durch
die Artillerie leidet. Wir haben also
immer mehr Videos, wo die ukrainischen Soldaten
einerseits versuchen zu erreichen,
dass sie mit besseren Waffen ausgestattet
werden, andererseits dass ihre Verwundeten versorgt
werden beziehungsweise sie zurückgenommen
werden, weil die unmittelbare Frontlinie gegenüber
den Russen nicht zu halten ist. Wir haben sogar
einen Gesetzesentwurf der nicht
angenommen worden ist, wo darin quasi verkündet
worden ist, dass ein Zurückgehen der Soldaten einer
Desertion gleichkommend sogar mit dem Tod
bestraft werden kann. Hier wissen wir aber, dass
dieses Gesetz nicht angenommen worden ist.
Während die ukrainische Seite unter diesen
massiven Abnutzungen durch die russischen
Angriffe leidet, ist es so, dass die Russen weiteren
Nachschub heranholen. Einerseits haben wir gesehen,
dass sie versuchen, T-62-Modelle heranzuführen, aber
andererseits auch T-80 und T-72. Jetzt könnte man
sagen, der T-62 ist ein Kampfpanzer, der sich
für das moderne Gefecht nicht eignet. Hier
muss man aber verstehen, dass in der Situation,
in der sich die Russen befinden, ein derartiger
moderner Kampfpanzer gar nicht notwendig ist.
Denn im Prinzip ist der Panzer eingesetzt
in der Gefechtstechnik zur Unterstützung
der angreifenden Infanterie. Er ist gepanzert,
beweglich und hat eine hohe Feuerkraft. Wir haben
also keine großen Panzerschlachten, wo Panzer
auf der ukrainischen und auf der russischen Seite
aufeinander treffen, wo ein modernes Fahrzeug
notwendig wäre. Trotzdem sehen wir auch, wie in
diesem nächsten Video, dass auch die russische
Seite sehr wohl noch modernere Modelle heranführt,
wie zum Beispiel auf diesem Zug mit T-80 beladen.
Während die russische Seite sukzessive
weitere Kräfte aus der Tiefe Russlands
heranführt, ist es so, dass sich die Versorgung
mit internationalen Waffenlieferungen immer mehr
zuspitzt. Es kristallisiert sich klar heraus,
dass es vor allem ein zentrales Waffensystem ist,
dass die Ukrainer brauchen, um der russischen
Artillerie entgegentreten zu können und das
sind Mehrfach-Raketenwerfer mit einer hohen Reichweite.
Dabei ist es interessant, dass es im Prinzip genau
um zwei Systeme geht: Von amerikanischer Seite
geliefert einerseits das "Multiple Launch Rocket System"
("MLRS") und andererseits das "High
Mobility Artillery Rocket System" ("HIMARS").
Diese Fahrzeuge können mit unterschiedlicher
Munition ausgestattet werden.
Diese Munitionssorten reichen von einer Distanz von
30 bis 70 Kilometer bis sogar zu 300 Kilometer.
Über die Lieferung dieser Waffensysteme aus
amerikanischen Beständen wurde in den letzten
Tagen eine sehr heftige Diskussion geführt. Ich
zeige das hier am Beispiel dieses Ausschnitts
aus einem Artikel der Zeitschrift Politico,
wo darauf hingewiesen wird, dass die
Lieferung dieser Systeme möglicherweise zu einer
Eskalation des Konflikts führt. Tatsächlich sah es
kurz so aus, als wenn die Vereinigten Staaten von
Amerika auf Entscheidung des US-Präsidenten
tatsächlich diese Waffensysteme liefern
würden. Jedoch in den letzten 48 Stunden gab es
die Entscheidung, das nicht durchzuführen. Das
bedeutet, dass die ukrainische Seite nicht
diese Waffensysteme geliefert bekommt, die sie aus
ihrer Sicht benötigen würde, um der russischen
Artillerie entsprechend entgegenwirken zu
können und diesen Abnützungseffekt, der auf
die ukrainischen Streitkräfte wirkt, verringern
zu können. Was wir wissen ist, dass bereits zwei
Nationen Raketenwerfer geliefert haben: Einmal
20 Stück von diesem RM-70 der tschechischen
Armee. Dieses System verschießt aber herkömmliche
alte sowjetische Raketen der Bauart 122mm.
Wir wissen auch, dass die polnischen Streitkräfte
20 Stück oder sogar mehr BM-21 "Grad" geliefert
haben - auch ein System, das eigentlich noch aus
sowjetischer Zeit kommt. Diese Systeme sind nicht
vergleichbar mit der Wirkung der Systeme die
wir vorher gesehen haben. Das bedeutet, dass die
Effektivität des Einsatzes gegen die russischen
Artillerie-Kampfgruppen natürlich verringert ist.
An dieser Stelle möchte ich enden.
Ich sage herzlichen Dank
fürs Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal!